[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the editor of
the career in dundee david clegg and the
political commentator salmer shah so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
the metro reports that according to the
bank of england inflation is likely to
exceed 10 percent later this year as the
cost of living crisis bites
the telegraph points out that we could
see the highest inflation for 40 years
and as you might expect that's also the
big story for the financial times
and also the guardian
the eye says that the average hit two
families will be around one thousand two
hundred pounds but there's no help in
sight until the next
all
budget
which says the mail amounts to a record
squeeze on families
while the time says there's growing
pressure from the cabinet for the
chancellor to cut taxes to stave off
recession
but the express says recession is
already on its way
david's paper the courier has spoken to
a woman who's housing two ukrainian
sisters who are refugees and who've been
forced to evade people trafficking gangs
even after they arrived in scotland
and in a follow-up to last night the sun
reports that the three-line's football
anthem has been saved for the nation
after the fa backtracked on plans to
ditch it
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by david clegg
and salmer sharp welcome to both of you
let's have a look at the telegraph front
page and um as we said they're running
through the front pages we're taking a
look at this
gloomy prediction of a recession not
technically in recession because we
haven't had two negative quarters but uh
governor bank of england is not um
positive about the future shall we say
david take us into this
yes you're going through the start of
the front pages there and it was almost
like a horror movie where there was one
scare after an another it
really is a fairly grim picture
that's that's echoed on the front of the
financial times i think it is tomorrow
by roger lee head of uk equity strategy
at investic and and his quote is this is
the sum of all our fears so we really
are at that situation where we're seeing
inflation topping 10 percent the
possibility of a recession next year
some speculation that the average cost
of fuel could go up uh to 2800 pounds
for the average household i was we saw
that some suggestion that this could all
cost 1200 pounds for uh each household
just the increase so it really is a
fairly bleak economic picture and i
think what the as you go through the
papers what that what what we're seeing
is that this is going to be a real
challenge for the uk government
and the chancellor rishi sunak in
particular about what he's going to do
about it because there's calls from
uh some cabinet ministers in fact in the
times uh for him to cut corporation tax
to perhaps cut vat and then he's also un
under a lot of pressure for more
progressive voices
for a stimulus package for perhaps a
windfall tax on the energy companies
which have been raking in such huge
profits uh during this
energy
uh this spiraling energy costs so i i
there is a suggestion that he's trying
to do nothing until the next budget but
i think given the
given the front pages we have here given
the report from the bank of england
today given the great concern that has
been expressed by all economists really
that we're facing the the greatest cost
of living crisis in 40 years maybe it it
feels like the pressure for some serious
government response to this now is
almost overwhelming yes selma that
that's certainly the case isn't it when
you read headlines like this uh highest
inflation in in 40 years this is an
emergency
yes and certainly i think that the
treasury uh is going to be under the
microscope in a way that it has
amazingly thus far avoided because
actually coming out of a pandemic where
the treasury has been incredibly
generous uh they aren't they are now
going to have to recalibrate i think
some of their assumptions about what
they were going to do with spending and
i think the front page of the telegraph
sort of alludes to this because there's
some
sentiments and quotes in there that say
that you know the prime minister is
going to put a bit of pressure on the
chancellor
to attempt to do something before the
next budget comes out i also think it's
very interesting um to see what impact
this is going to have i mean not
directly because there's not enough time
for it to have had an impact but on the
local elections and what this then means
if you try and extrapolate what the cost
of living crisis is going to do from
polling and what that means for a future
general election which is really not
that far away so i think the pressure is
on both you know most importantly uh you
know for the reality of people's cost of
living but also for the politics of the
situation yes you mentioned there the
local election summer we're seeing live
pictures from wandsworth we know that
all 58 seats of the council are up for
election there uh one of the councils
that could potentially uh change hands
and swing towards a
labor um although it might go to no
overall control so one of the one of the
councils to watch um let's continue
without our review and have a look at
the financial times
um what everybody will be thinking is
how how is this going to affect me and
the financial times is talking about
household pain and it really is going to
be pain those with mortgages i mean
everyone is going to hurt aren't they
david
yes i don't i don't think there's
there's not a
there's there's not a silver lining i
can pick out for you i'm afraid i don't
think there's there's much light on the
horizon there i think really whether
it's a homeowner well or it's someone
who's worried about fuel costs whether
it's a small business owner
basically everything's going to get more
expensive
and the
the impact of that also is going to be
the there's
buried in the in the bank of england
predictions today there is talk about
rising unemployment which i think could
reach five percent i believe from memory
so we're going to start to see that go
through to the job market so there is
this
this issue that talmud was talking to to
there which is that the government is
going to be facing pressure on this at a
point when we suspect after tomorrow
with perhaps some
uh somewhat uh unimpressive election
results behind them whether there is
going to be this
sense where the public are going to be
disgruntled but also i think very
worried and fearful for their future
they've just came through karuna virus
we've just came through this national
emergency this global emergency and
we're now facing what looks like a
really really um difficult indeed
possibly once in a lifetime economic
crisis as well so
it's all it's all stacking up and the
main takeaway from me would be i'm glad
i'm not the chancellor of the exchequer
yes no no it is extremely depressing and
the bank saying as you alluding to that
the energy price
crunch will leave a lasting scar pushing
up unemployment and uh weak and negative
growth throughout 2023 um there is no
silver lining it seems selma
no and what's interesting about the ft
piece is that they're also referencing
the fact that uh three people on the mpc
which is the monetary policy committee
that decide where interest rates go um
actually wanted to put it up a little
bit more yeah so
yeah
it just goes to show that there's a lot
of um
difference of opinion but you know the
fact that there were three members that
wanted for it to go up a further half
percent than where it's at uh is that
actually they feel that the inflation is
really going to get out of control so i
sort of slightly worried that 10
at the end of this year is perhaps a bit
of a conservative estimate from the bank
of england so this is going to be
really quite painful really quite
quickly for a lot of people and the
government is going to have to
reconsider how it wants to respond to
this
let us move away we could stay with uh
the economy and inflation let's have a
look at the um telegraph it is the front
page and this is a story about uh covert
deaths in relation to sweden and their
anti-lockdown policy david
yes well i think it's interesting
because it's a it's a world health
organization report which has came out
which has looked at uh the cover death
situation across the world actually and
what it's been looking at as excess
death rate so what they're trying to
work out is because there's concerns
across the across the globe has everyone
been calculating deaths properly have
some people been some countries been on
reporting the number of deaths in their
area and what they feel is a more
sophisticated measure of how places have
responded to the pandemic is this excess
death rate which
in sweden they're saying which is known
for having been had a very casual
lockdown approach uh they're saying it's
better than many other places in europe
i think that's a that's probably a line
on that report on editorial line on that
report which reflects the telegraph's
distaste for lockdown more than anything
else because if you go further into the
report you'll find that one of the
lowest excess death rates in the world
was
was australia which actually imposed
very stringent lockdowns and indeed uh
travel restrictions so i think it's
actually a really interesting report
that the telegraph touches on there
which has other issues in it which are
worth looking into about you know
indirect deaths this this idea of the
number of deaths that were caused not by
the virus itself but also
excess deaths that wouldn't have
happened if the virus hadn't been there
because hospitals weren't operating
properly because people were behaving
differently and not getting checked out
for stuff that they should have been
getting checked out before so it's an
interesting story yes no very
interesting uh we've just got time we
are running out of time sadly um salma
can you take a look at the courier uh
for us i know it's david's paper but but
this uh story about uh people
trafficking in relation to ukrainian
refugees
yes so this is fascinating because it's
very much a brilliant sort of local
perspective on an international story
and i believe david's going to correct
me if i'm wrong but a local uh lady
has
been waiting for two women to arrive um
that she's going to take in as refugees
who have basically been harassed and
have been at risk of people trafficking
and i think this just serves to
underline
that uh refugees coming over are not
having an easy time on the journey let
alone when they arrive here um and
really exposes some of the risks that
they're under from uh criminal gangs and
major exploitation
salma thank you david was nodding in
agreement so i think he's a she got it
she got it perfect and she can have a
job on our communications team any time
she should there you go
approval there thank you both david and
salman